[Aplausos]
se trató de un Exterminio político ante
los ojos de un país entero la historia
del partido de la unión patriótica up de
lata parte de la crueldad de la
violencia vivida en Colombia a finales
del siglo XX el partido nació en 1985
producto de unas negociaciones entre la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC y el
gobierno del expresidente colombiano
Belisario Betancourt su bandera Amarilla
simbolizaba un deseo convertir al
partido en una alternativa en un
escenario político dominado por décadas
por dos partidos tradicionales el
liberal y el conservador su conformación
se convirtió en una tercera vía y fue
vista como una posibilidad de
representación política para una parte
del electorado a la vez buscaba ser un
mecanismo de transición de las armas a
la política de las Farc
en 1986 consiguieron 15 escaños en el
congreso
pero su proyecto quedó inconcluso por el
asesinato de sus representantes año tras
año la violencia fue perpetrada por
grupos paramilitares en Alianza con
sectores de la política tradicional la
fuerza pública y grupos empresariales
así lo anunciaba su líder en los años 90
desde luego que nosotros sabemos muy
bien cómo son las conexiones de estos
grupos con con autoridades y con la
propios sectores de la inteligencia
militar una violencia con enormes
dimensiones que incluso cobró la vida de
dos candidatos presidenciales en 2002 el
Consejo Nacional electoral le retiró la
personería jurídica al no conseguir
escaños suficientes una decisión
cuestionada solo entre 1984 y 2002 según
cifras del observatorio de memoria y
conflicto más de 3000 de sus miembros
fueron asesinados
hasta este lunes sólo 219 víctimas eran
reconocidas oficialmente por el estado
colombiano y su responsabilidad era solo
vista de manera indirecta ahora
condenado el estado deberá saldar parte
de su deuda histórica con sus familiares
y sobrevivientes